I don't know about you,
but my favorite thing on TikTok is the food.
And in the past year, you've probably seen how-to videos
for the tortilla wrap, the mini pancake cereal,
and the whipped coffee.
These delicious videos got a combined 30.9 million views.
So clearly, this is so exciting,
and I love this too, because I'm a parent.
So I'm like, what's the kids doing on TikTok.
And I just like to be up in the know,
and our next guest is back on the show for her second time.
First time in person.
To show us the newest and yummiest TikTok food trend.
Please welcome lifestyle expert, friend of the show,
Michelle Park.
(applause)
I'm excited!
And you're real!
I'm here in person.
So cool.
I'm so excited because this is the hottest trend right now.
There are two.
It's the tomato feta pasta.
Like, how would you describe it?
It's everywhere.
Everybody's making this baked feta pasta.
People have started swapping out the ingredients
with fun, new ones.
It's like, it's taken on a whole new life.
But this is the original, and it is delicious.
Okay, so we're also going to maybe touch on
the accordion potato, which is also trending like crazy.
But the reason I was so excited to do this
is 'cause I haven't done it yet.
I'm seeing it everywhere, and I want to be in the club.
So teach me.
So Drew, we're gonna start
with this big empty casserole dish
and you're going to take your grape tomatoes,
or cherry tomatoes, if that's what you have,
and just throw them in there.
And then throw your shallots in there.
I mean, there's no, like, real technique to this.
You're just throwing everything together.
So you kind of spread it around,
but the whole point is to just have fun with that.
Right.
And then take your olive oil
and just give it a good drizzle.
We're also going to do a little salt and pepper,
as much as you normally like.
And then if you're into the spice,
you can sprinkle a little red pepper on there.
I like-
I'm into spice.
And now make yourself a little hole in the middle.
'Cause we're gonna put our feta cheese right in there.
Okay.
And now you can put your thyme
that you've got there on top.
I like to put a little bit more red pepper flake
just for good measure.
It also makes it look nice and pretty.
Now all you need to do with this
is stick it in the oven at 400 for 40 minutes.
400, 40, got it.
And then it's gonna come out,
it's gonna look like this.
So now we have this guy here.
Beautiful.
And all you have to do now
is just stick your pasta in this
and we're going to mix it up
and you will see how creamy and just coaty
and beautiful this feta turned out.
Now, oh my gosh, okay.
Yeah.
So if yours is now nicely incorporated,
there's a little, you could eat out of the fancy plate,
but I think we should just eat out of the ones that we made.
Mm.
That's the stuff.
Mm hm.
All right, now take me through the potatoes, Michelle.
All right, let's do it.
This is the other
hot, hot, hot TikTok trend.
Can't get away from, and it's called accordion potatoes.
Yes, because you can kind of stretch them out
and then push them back together, like an accordion.
So I'm going to show you how to do this,
but the tip that I have for you is,
since we're going to be cutting them
but we don't want to cut them all the way through,
if you have chopsticks
you can, like, kind of place them like this.
So you don't end up chopping through them, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I totally get it.
It's like a barrier.
Yes. It's like a,
we call it, like,
chopping potatoes for dummies.
So first you're going to cut it just straight down
and kind of close together.
Okay, Michelle, this chopstick barrier
is so brilliant.
Thank you.
No, really, this is a brilliant hack.
Allright, so if you've done the first side,
you're just going to flip it over
and now when you cut it you're going to cut on a diagonal
instead of straight down.
Okay.
Because this is how you're going to get it to
kind of fan out.
Okay, diagonal.
Yes.
This is cool.
So what you're gonna do next is you're gonna skewer it.
This part is potentially dangerous.
So I just recommend anyone who's trying to do it at home,
make sure you're wearing gloves or something
so that you don't poke your finger.
'cause you could draw some blood.
And once it is skewered, it will look like this.
(Drew grunts)
I was gonna use my stomach.
What am I doing wrong, Michelle?
It's very, very difficult
to actually get the skewer in there.
So you want to kinda slowly work it through.
Gosh.
(banging sound)
Well that's a new technique.
(audience laughs)
(banging sound)
Okay.
So I'm gonna show you how to butter this thing up.
So we have butter, Italian seasoning,
garlic, thyme,
you know, you can actually put any herbs you want in here.
So whatever you're into.
Or whatever's preferential.
Yes.
Butter is the most important part, in my opinion.
Well, yeah.
So now this.
You're gonna lay them all flat on a baking sheet,
20 minutes on each side at 400 degrees.
And then they come out looking like that.
Okay.
And then, now we get to actually eat it.
Mm.
Back to the pasta.
You know, this one I got.
This one is really carefree
and, like, less intimidating.
But it was fun to do it with you, Drew.
Well, apparently I can't do it.
I just have to accept that.
So I'm gonna drown my problems in these gorgeous noodles
that are dressed in feta and tomato.
And Michelle, I can't thank you enough
for making me feel like I am in the club.
Thank you.
This is what I always do.
I just eat, and then I can't do anything.
Thank you, Michelle.
Thank you, Drew.
(upbeat music)